这是由几个不同的因素导致的
我们等会儿会逐一讨论
你可以利用ralph loop构建出非常酷的东西
他们极大地扩展了任务的处理范围
你可以把任务交给AI智能体
并期待他能顺利完成
即便如此
实现ralph loop的方式有很多种
它们的实用性
以及对JEFF最初想要创造的那种感觉的
还原程度也各不相同
RYANCARSON做的很棒
他拆解了一份分布指南
教你如何让RFLOOP运行并交付代码
他甚至上传了一个GITHUB仓库
详细描述了这些内容
还包括一个RH点SH文件
以及你所需的一切
JEFF回复说
事情并不是这样的
并附上了一个视频链接
专门解释了为什么CD co的实现方式
其实并不是rough loop
所以你在cloud co等工具中使用的插件
可能并不是真正的rough loop
有很多个人实现的版本
比如BEN就有一个用于ALEXA应用的版本
来自come max的mickey
也分享了一个版本
里面包含很多自定义设置和额外功能
这里有很多内容可以聊
我想试着拆解说明
让你理解什么是rough loop
你是否想要使用它
以及最重要的一点
你该如何将这些想法融入日常工作中
从而在利用AI工具时变得更高效
即便如此
我还是得引用力的话
Ralpon my wim
直到我合并代码
在那之后
我可能真的需要在深入研究历史之前
我认为初步了解什么是ralph loop也很重要
简单来说
它就是在BS循环中执行你的AI智能体
这样他们就可以根据需要一直运行下去
虽然实现方式有很多种
但如果我们去看看最初关于RALPH的帖子
就能看到这个事例
在while true循环中执行cut prompt点MD
并通过管道传给clolck code
就这样一直运行
这个版本真的会永远运行下去
除非你手动停止它
而这正是RPLOOP的创造者最常做的操作
那位rh loop的创造者
围绕这个主题拍了一段我见过的最混乱的视频
这视频看着并不轻松
如果你感兴趣的话
链接会放在描述栏里
但我会尽力提炼其中的经验教训
以及你能从中获得的价值
还有具体的构建方式
我认为
即便我们不一定非要按提议的特定方式去使用
它
也可以从这种策略中学到很多东西
JEFF最初开发rap loop
是为了构建一些相当疯狂的东西
也就是从零开始开发一门完整的编程语言
实际上早在他在做这件事的时候
我就已经专门做了一个视频
因为我觉得这太酷了
但为了实现这一点
你必须改变智能体的执行方式
智能体执行方式的一个重要组成部分
就是上下文
当你使用cloud code这样的工具工作时
历史记录会被传入已进行token生成
你必须记住AI的工作方式
仅仅是下一个token的预测
所以如果我说美国的首都是AI所做的全部工作
就是根据上下文中之前的所有内容
来猜测下一个词是什么
它是通过极其复杂的参数映射来实现的
使其能够根据当前的聊天历史和已有的token
计算出最有可能的下一个token
不过这里也有一些限制
特别是上下文限制
在这些预测算法变得非常差之前
上下文只能容纳有限的文本量
有些模型能处理的长度比其他模型多得多
但如果结果导致质量下降
那也就没有意义了
质量下降有一个专门的术语叫做上下文腐烂
记住这一点非常重要
因为这是ralph loop如此有趣的一个重要原因
当上下文中信息过多时
就会发生上下文腐烂
导致模型表现变差
像CLOCO这样的工具采取的解决方案是压缩
你可以通过输入斜杠compact手动触发
或者当你超出上下文窗口时
它会为你执行压缩
即将现有历史记录发送给模型
他会说嘿总结一下这个
并提取所有关键细节
然后将其作为新的历史记录
所以当你与cloud code cursor
或其他AI智能体进行来回沟通时
每当你发送一条消息
它就会被添加到上下文中
然后模型会执行一堆操作
这些内容现在也被添加到了上下文中
接着你发送一个后续问题
模型会添加更多内容
每当有任何事情发生时
它都在不断追加
所以这第一条消息可能是20个token
你得到的回复可能是我不确定
假设是5000个token
然后你说又是一个20个token的后续问题
接着又是一五千个token
当你发送这个20个token的后续问题时
模型解析的不仅仅是这20个token
而是20加上之前的20
加上之前的5000
因为他正在便利并发送整个历史记录
当你发送一条消息时
之前的所有内容都会被发送
当你达到限制
或者仅仅是到了上下文过于臃肿
准确度下降的程度
情况就会变糟
正如我之前所说
大多数工具使用的解决方案是
一旦他们遇到这种情况
且长度太长时
系统会发送一个类似请总结的提示词
这个总结会被作为一个全新的内容发送
我们假设总结后的上下文是蓝色的
他会把这2万个token变成一个更小的数字
比如5000个token的总结
然后模型继续生成
就像什么也没发生过一样
但这种方式其实存在很多问题
有些细节可能会丢失
比如假设你这里有一个非常重要的细节
比如始终读取这个特定文件
然后当模型压缩你的上下文时
他丢掉了那个指令
现在任何你认为重要的上下文也都丢失了
rh loop的核心点之一就是抛弃这套压缩模式
与其让每个提示词都追加到你的历史记录中
rough loop的目标是
将每个后续提示词都作为其独立的
全新的历史记录处理
不过这里有一个问题
如果你拥有历史记录中非常重要的信息
你会丢失它
这就是rail floop的许多实现细节
发挥作用的地方
所有的细节
所有的实现以及所有让它变得有趣的东西
都在于你如何将正确的信息放入提示词中
以便你能以循环方式运行
而不是运行到结束
然后再发送后续指令
如果你运行到了最后该怎么办
你已更新一些重要的信息
然后从头开始启动一个新实例
来继续之前正在进行的工作
想象一位非常优秀的工程师
每当他一次处理太多工作时
大脑就会被清空
所以如果你有这样一位
能建造任何东西的顶尖工程师
但一旦他写了太多行代码
他的记忆就会被清空
不得不从头开始
你实际上是在构建一套技术
以足够快的速度让他重新掌握适量的信息
从而使他能高效地回到工作中
这就是RALPHFLOOP
许多有趣之处所在
我喜欢RYAN拆解这件事的方式
即便它不是一个标准的rough lue
我认为它也是一个很好的例子
这是一个将提示词通过管道传给你的智能体
agent的bash循环智能体
从PRD中挑选下一个用户故事
PRD是描述你想要完成的工作的规划文档
智能体根据它来实现那个故事
它运行类型检查和测试
如果通过了
他就会提交代码
并将该故事标为已完成记录学习心得
然后循环往复
直到所有工作完成
这就是关键所在
记忆的持久化
它仅通过执行git提交来持久化事物和信息记忆
所以它是通过将学到的内容
更新到一个名为progress点TXT的文件
来保留记忆的
因此它不保留全部上下文
而只是保留重要的关键部分
还有PRDJ3文件
他负责跟踪所有正在完成的任务的状态
实现这一点有很多种不同的方法
例如原作者建议的做法是
与模型进行多次来回沟通
为你想要完成的工作编写一份详尽的计划
其中包含所有需要完成的不同任务
将该计划保存在代码库某个位置的文件中
在这种情况下
它是inspect斜杠ANALYTICS下划线
implementation下划线
plan点MD
这里重要的指令是挑选最重要的事情来做
而不是按顺序执行
从中挑选你认为最重要的内容并着手处理
一旦完成下次运行时
它就会选择不同的任务
当他完成一项任务时
这个markdown文件就会更新
所以他在这里加入
当任务完成时更新实施计划
这是关键
但这也是适用于cloud code的RALPHWIGAM插件
开始出现问题的地方
最初的纺织品是JEFFHUNTLEY的
那个简单的while true循环
这个插件的工作方式相当不同
循环发生在当前的绘画内部
这听起来很方便
但遗憾的是会引发一系列问题
因为当它在一个绘画中运行时
就不再有干净的历史记录作为起点了
它不断导致上下文窗口溢出
然后不得不回头进行压缩
结果有时会导致他搞不清楚自己在做什么
如果你把这些东西看作盒子或者层级
我们在外层看到的是理想状态下的cloud code
它遵循官方的RALPHWIGAM思路
所以rough loop是存在于cloud code之外的东西
因为这样他就可以随时将其关闭并重新实例化
而且CLAUDIO的历史记录无法控制任何事情
这实际上是让cloud co脱离了控制
现在的真相来源是那个markdown或者JSON文件
它描述了bush循环中正在进行的工作
该循环会触发工作
然后由全新的智能体继续执行
该插件的问题在于
它反转了这种关系
由cloud code控制ralph loop
而不是ralph loop控制cloud code
这意味着许多优势会立即消失
如果你使用rough loop
只是想让它无限期的运行下去
并且不在乎压缩问题
那么使用这个插件实际上是阻止了cloud code
说出我完成了
你认为在上下文激增以及原始提示中
重要数据可能丢失的情况下
它依然能运行良好吗
行吧
你可以这样做
但我个人并没在这上面取得太大成功
我认为很多在RWFLOOP上挣扎的人
大概也是在以这种方式使用它
我知道我以前就是这么用的
而且没见什么成效
但当我与BEN这样的人交流时
他们使用的是另一种方式
也就是在外部用脚本包装代码
他们取得了大得多的成功
我也计划亲自尝试一下这种方法
还有一个重要的环节
那就是你如何判断任务何时完成
经典的RPHOP实现方式是手动停止
当有人出于各种原因
认为工作可能已经完成时
就会介入并叫停
这可能并不理想
所以其他的实现方式会包含某种
让模型指示工作已完成的方法
例如在RYAN的实现中
它在提示词中向模型明确规定
当完成计划文件中的所有工作时
应当输出promise
Complete
Close promise
如果我们从结果中看到这一指令
我们就退出循环
否则我们就继续
你也可以设置最大迭代次数
这样如果运行时间太长
它就会自动停止
并不是所有人都这样做
包括JEFF也没做
但你或许应该设置一下
以确保不会浪费你所有的token
顺便说一下
这确实会消耗很多token
我相信你在开始前就很清楚这一点
但在你投入使用时
请务必明确这一点
BRYAN还发布了一些prompt
点MD以及PRDJSON的事例
它顶部的这里漏掉了一些重要的信息
比如我非常喜欢JEFF视频中的做法
他在顶部明确要求研究规格说明或read me文件
该文件包含了所有的规格
以及项目的概况和运行方式
这样在启动时
他就在正确的语境下拥有了适量的上下文
然后还要研究你正在构建的实施方案
并挑选出最重要的任务去做
这会在一开始就为你提供正确的上下文
这是最重要的事情之一
如果你没有完整的历史记录
因为你不再保留历史
你就需要花心思
确保这第一部分里包含正确的信息
不一定非要包含代码库中需要了解的所有内容
但要包含有关他需要了解代码库
哪些顶层信息的指令
以及关于如何寻找可能需要的更多信息的指令
与直觉相反
这其实完全没问题
即便你在这个框里告诉他去读取某些文件
然后他必须在每一个实例中都去获取
该文件的内容
也没关系
这看起来可能有点浪费
比如为什么不直接把信息放进去呢
这其中有很多原因
但最好让模型自己决定是否需要那项信息
只要确保他知道去哪里找就行了
模型拥有很好的搜索
grab以及查找信息的工具
但他们不知道自己应该去查找什么信息
确保你给它提供了获取信息的正确路径
这是最关键的部分之一
所以这就是一个提示词的例子
每当创建一个新实例时
它就会被反复喂入
任务是读取PRD文件
读取进度文件
先检查代码库模式
并检查你是否在正确的分支上
我觉得你没必要非得加上这一条
挑选优先级最高且pass4字段为false的用户故事
实现这一个故事运行类型检查和测试更新
智能体编写记录学习成果的markdown文件提交功能
更新PRDJSON
并将学习成果追加到progress点text
后面
这个方法存在一个问题
就是如果他无法在一次运行中完成工作
即便工作只是一个用户故事
也有可能出现一个故事或一个任务失败
或者需要多次运行的情况
我在这里见过的大多数情况是检查progress点TXT
看看任务是否正在进行中
如果没有完成就继续执行
如果空间耗尽前没能完成
就在progress点TXT中注明此过程中学到的东西
然后我们有一个一个p r d j sun的例子
这也可以只是一个带复选框的markdown文件
不过这是一个非常简单的格式
分支名称
然后是用户故事被存储为一个键值对数组
包含了该特定分支的所有用户故事
添加登录表单以及验收标准
这些是你期望在成功后他能做到的事情
他们并不是真正的测试用例
但这也是AI有趣的地方之一
这一切都非常混乱且具有不确定性
但验收标准的定义可以模糊很多
嗯也可能是你编写了测试
并确保它们通过
只要智能体拥有正确的验证工具和知识
来确保事物真实存在
可能这种能力就已经存在
并由智能体去验证过了
你就随便在这里放一段文本
它就能工作
这有点疯狂
但也非常棒
这里的关键部分是代表通过状态的布尔值
一旦它为true
这个故事就可以跳过并开始处理其他的任务了
再说一次
模型并不会逐一过一遍
然后一个接一个的执行
他会查看列表
选择他认为最重要的事情
然后直接去做
我很想多聊聊验收标准
因为我觉得这里有一些很酷的操作
显然像单元测试这样的东西
比以往任何时候都更重要
类型检查
确保类型检查通过
以及为模型提供正确的命令来执行类型检查
这都是非常实用的东西
增加一些功能
比如使用某种形式的浏览器技能
在浏览器中进行测试
以便我们可以在chrome中检查一切是否符合预期
这会非常有帮助
但也可能成本很高
且会显著降低模型速度
我发现有一件被低估的事情
非常有用的是使用AI编程CLI
比如code rabbit
你可以进行工具调用
甚至将其作为循环的一部分
或者在运行结束后
针对当前的def运行code rabbit CLI
找出代码中任何可能存在的问题
然后将其作为上下文的一部分
发送给另一个智能体
由他去修复发现的问题
这超级超级有帮助
可以让你交付的代码质量显著提升
我正考虑更进一步
建立一个专门供智能体使用的get it实例
并让code rabbit作为precommit go子运行
事实上
当你以这种方式构建时
PRECOMMIT钩子非常有意义
因为除非你能确保代码正常工作
否则你不希望他提交代码
火箭由于AI运作方式的不同
我对这些事情的很多看法正在发生改变
比如以前
我绝对不想在任何项目中添加pre commit钩子
因为他们会让开发者的生活变得非常糟糕
这种必须先验证一大堆东西
才能提交代码的想法真的很烂
我不想让任何人类开发人员经历这些
但我很乐意让一些智能体去应付这些
为了帮助大家建立心理模型
最后我想说明一个重点
特别是当你将它与其他使用AI进行
大型构建的方案进行对比时
想象一下你有一个大项目
并且已经把它拆分成了若干任务
如果是传统的工作方式
通常会说好人员甲负责这些任务
人员乙负责
那些剩下的由谁有空或者谁先干完活
谁来接手
结果就是你把大量的工作都并行化了
所以不同的工作可以同时进行
但一旦你这样做
事情就会变得复杂得多
你必须担心冲突啊
你得担心大家的工作互相干扰
你还得担心那些可能依赖于其他环节的事情
这会让场面迅速变得混乱
如果你没有记忆的话
因为这又是核心部分之一
一旦触及上下文窗口
智能体就不得不压缩信息或继续推进
从而丢失他们之前做过的一切
如果你被分配去处理任务六七和八
结果发现七被二阻塞了
你就会一遍又一遍的卡在那里
因为除非你有特定的处理方式
否则这些知识是不会一直保留的
RAFFLU很有趣的一大原因在于
他抛弃了整个传统模型
他并不试图将工作拆分成不同的小组
由不同的人并行完成
而是告诉模型
he选一个你认为最重要的事情先做
模型会说好的任务六
于是他就开始做了任务六
然后他完成了这个任务
现在他变绿了
因为搞定了
然后你再问剩下的任务里哪个最重要
他看了看所有的任务
说我要做任务三好他做了任务三
现在这也完成了
结果就是这一切都是线性完成的
虽然不是按照固定的顺序
不是123456这样排队
但他确实是线性执行的
它是先做六再做三
然后是一和二
而不是在做一和二的同时并行去做六合七
通过舍弃并行性
你最终降低了大量的复杂性
这使得这种方法更加可靠
尽管如此
如果工作划分的足够开
比如任务一和任务二
与任务七和任务八真的完全不同
而且你在密切关注着进度
也许你可以在你的机器上
把它们拆分给不同的并行智能体
但如果说我在使用这些工具的过程中
学到了什么
那就是由于我们的开发环境还没准备好
并行处理会很快让人感到非常沮丧
如果你是用cloud code davin github最近在搞的那个东西
或者是cursor的后台工具来运行后台智能体
那可能还行
但我还没找到一个
能让我用的顺手的这种工作流
我还是更喜欢在自己的机器上
用自己的工具运行这些最后一件事
因为我觉得了解这里不同的观点立场很重要
这里的peter是我见过最有天赋的
智能体编程者之一
在AI浪潮出现之前
他就是一名非常正统的工程师
他曾经成功创业并退出
他现在过得很不错
而且比以往任何时候都更投入于编程
我之前展示过他的GITHUB
那看起来简直不可思议
因为他最近正积极参与的项目实在太多了
简直疯了
有时候他在一天之内就能提交超过500次commit
是他在12月28日提交了534次
太假了
所以你肯定以为像他这样的人
正在疯狂使用rough loop对吧
才没有
它主要使用的是code x
我发现codex实际上非常擅长处理
这类超长时间运行的任务
并且在运行一段时间进行compaction时
往往能更好地遵循原始提示词的初衷
这是他让他做的一个改动
涉及393个文件
新增了8000行代码
并删除了近7000行
有人猜
他为了这个改动写的提示词肯定超级复杂
可能分解成了很多步骤
其实并没有
他只说了一句
将providers重命名为messaging channels
这就是全部的提示词
而模型能够持续运行很长时间来完成它
所以如果你使用rough loop
只是为了完成更长的任务
或者让它在某个任务上运行更久
你可能根本不需要它
我自己也遇到过这种烦心事
我写好一个计划
让他确认
然后说好去执行吧
然后他执行到一半就停了
他会说好了
我完成了第一阶段
告诉我你的想法
以及我什么时候该开始
第二阶段
Ralph loop
某种程度上能解决这个问题
但这依然让人非常恼火
简直荒谬
我也觉得那不是重点
RPFLOOP的目标并不是要解决智能体
停止太早的问题
rph loop的目标是
让你用一种完全不同的方式进行构建
即通过线性编排智能体
来完成PRD文档中许多不同的相关工作
这种更长时间运行的工作方式
正是pt t相比cloud code
更倾向于使用code x和gt4.5的重要原因
他过去甚至在文章中提到过
他让他去清理opp s4.0
留下的那些陈年烂摊子
hold dex的最大区别在于
在写代码之前
他会静默阅读文件十到15分钟
一方面这挺让人着急的
另一方面这又很神奇
因为它大大增加了找准痛点并修复它的几率
opus表现的更急躁
这对于小修小改很不错
但对于大型重构或新功能就不太行了
正如他在这里指出的
他通常不会通读整个文件或者漏掉部分内容
导致交付的结果
效率低下或有所疏漏
还记得刚才那个文件吗
studies spec read me点MD
studies spec analytics implementation plan点MD
这些东西的存在是为了让模型更有可能
从正确的地方切入
因为这才是问题的核心
模型的表现上限取决于他们拥有的上下文
我们今天谈论的一切
无论是ralph loop还是PETE
使用code x的方式
亦或是所有的PRD内容
本质上都是关于context engineering
直到现在我才抛出这个词
因为我知道只要一提起他
人们就会听不进去
甚至感到大脑过载
但这在当下确实至关重要
确保在火车出发前装载好正确的货物
是这些工具运作的核心逻辑
也是我们正确使用它们的方式
而这一切的意义在于
做好上下文工程
从而最大限度地提高智能体成功的可能性
所以归根结底
RALPFLOOP就是通过bash脚本循环调用智能体
具体的工作方式差异很大
希望你通过这个视频学到的
不是我也该去弄个RALFLOOP
而是重新思考
当你用智能体开发真实软件时
该如何管理他们的上下文
这一趟旅程挺混乱的
但我希望你从中有所收获
从RPFUP的历史到他们为什么有用
我们正在进入一个全新的世界
我理解大家的兴奋感
但我们真的应该去学习其中的门道
而不是盲目追求那些被炒作的术语和工具
希望这能帮你理清思路
我知道在我学习这些东西的过程中
他对我非常有帮助
让我知道你的想法
下次再见
书呆子没